versailles au nord l'histoire 180
historiens et écrivains ont participé à
la 9e édition du salon histoire de lire
le week end du 26 et 27 novembre entre
10000 et 15000 personnes sont venues à
la rencontre des auteurs une
satisfaction pour les organisateurs
l'histoire de lire c'est vraiment de
transmettre la passion de l'histoire
bien sûr on vendait les bien sûr il ya
un côté librairie d'histoire mais c'est
d'abord une transmission delà de la
passion pour l'histoire yvelinois de
cette édition erik orsenna est venu
présenter son dernier ouvrage l'origine
de nos amours
le romancier versailles y raconte ses
confidences avec son père concernant les
relations avec les femmes
la ville royale en toile de fond tous
les dimanches pendant trente ans nous
nous rendions rendez nous de donner
rendez vous au restaurant la flottille
qui est au bord du canal
j'aime versa il se doit beaucoup à
versailles son arrivée dans la région
versaillaise quand j'avais 15 ans je
l'équité sans jamais la quitter quand
j'avais 42
je me devais de venir à versailles ne
serait ce que pour dire merci
l'histoire c'est aussi les présidents de
la république ancien conseiller
diplomatique du président socialiste
hubert védrine à rééditer lé monde de
françois mitterrand il explique la
gestion des controverses géopolitique
par la france dans les années 80-90
professeur d'histoire politique jean
garrigues à lui détaillé l'incarnation
de la fonction présidentielle
dans un ouvrage illustré intitulé
président au coeur du pouvoir et c'est
très intéressant d'avoir les réactions
ça peut être des lettres aussi mais rien
ne remplace le contact direct
parce que souvent les gens qui viennent
ils ont déjà lu d'autres livres dont ils
ont des idées où ils ont vu une émission
donc c'est un élément qui est amendé
biens indispensables à la maturation de
la réflexion pour les livres suivants
d'échangés toujours extrêmement
fructueux je comprends mieux ce qui peut
intéresser les lecteurs j'essaie de leur
expliquer aussi de quoi parlent eux par
le mail yves et et j'en sors toujours
très enrichi donc c'est vraiment un
plaisir
l'an prochain le salon histoire de lire
fêtera son dixième anniversaire de
nombreuses surprises sont d'ores et déjà
prévues